the United States military takes out
Iran's leading terrorists Democrats
lament the escalation and Bernie Sanders
prepares his final political assault on
Joe Biden I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show this show is sponsored
by expressvpn stop putting your online
data at risk just stop it get protected
at expressvpn dot-com slash bet okay
well you may have noticed that things
have gotten a little bit hot and heavy
in the opening moments of year 2020 this
might be a good time to diversify your
asset base just a little bit I mean we
may be headed to war things are chaotic
out there at the very least we are
headed into a tumultuous year now would
be a very good time to take some of your
money and put in a hard asset that has
never been more zero I of course I'm
talking about precious metals the
wealthiest people have a plan for
inflation and instability especially
during an election year certain times a
foreign policy crisis what is your plan
to safeguard your savings Fox Business
actually just published an article on
how the world's richest people are
stockpiling precious metals right now
and that according to Goldman Sachs gold
could actually surge past 1600 bucks an
ounce
within the next year if you haven't
taken the first step of actually
gathering information you need to go
over to Birch gold Birch gold we'll go
to work make things super simple for you
they'll have a conversation with you and
you can determine if precious metals
make sense for you there's no obligation
you have nothing to lose take that first
step Birch gold group has thousands of
satisfied customers countless five-star
reviews an A+ rating with the Better
Business Bureau I know them I've been
working with them for years as you know
from listening to the show text been to
47 47 47 today see how simple and
straightforward this move can be for you
again
text Ben - 47 47 47 text my name that's
been - 47 47 47 get all your questions
answered and then think about
diversifying into some precious metals
text Ben - 47 47 47 alrighty so
yesterday it was probably the most
consequential day for Trump foreign
policy in the history of his
administration it's not close actually I
won't say probably it is clearly the
most consequential day for Trump's
foreign policy in the history of his
administration President Trump made the
decision to go ahead with an attack at
the Baghdad Airport on general Qasem
Soleimani who is the leading terrorist
probably on planet earth certainly
inside Iran he also happened to be the
leader of the Iranian military as the
head of Iran's elite codes force which
was sort of the terrorist
of the Iranian Revolutionary Guard he
was widely considered the number-two in
Iran after Ayatollah Ali Khamenei he was
responsible for the deaths of hundreds
of Americans in Iraq he was really
leading the Iranian terror against
American troops during the Iraq war he
was responsible for by State Department
estimates 17% of all Americans killed in
Iraq he was responsible for the arming
of Hezbollah in Lebanon with tens of
thousands of rockets which is a
situation that will cascade into war
sometime in the next three to four years
that is all his work he's responsible
for the war in Yemen he has armed the
Houthis in Yemen and led to their
rebellion against a Saudi sponsored
regime in Yemen he's responsible for the
building of Islamic Jihad in the Gaza
Strip which is the terror group that is
responsible for firing rockets he's
responsible probably for the Bashar
Assad regime still running Syria
it was Iranian coordination with the
Bashar al-assad regime that allowed the
Assad regime to stand he's responsible
for the attacks on the American Embassy
that happened over the last week he's
been responsible for terror attacks
abroad like a bevy of them this was one
of the worst people on planet earth he
was a vicious terrorist who was
extremely effective at what he did
commentators have been describing him as
something in Iran the the situation at
the top of the Iranian government is
somewhat top-heavy meaning that there
are a few very key players who hold a
wide portfolio Soleimani was maybe the
most indispensable man in Iran people
have been comparing his death to like
let's say that there were a coordinated
strike against the United States in
which the defense secretary a head of
the CIA and head of the FBI were killed
simultaneously and maybe the VP because
Soleimani was widely considered a
possible heir apparent to all a Khomeini
should how many have died or something
and now he is in a thousand pieces
according to the Associated Press the
United States killed Iran's top General
and the architect of 10 Ron's proxy wars
in the Middle East in an airstrike at
Baghdad International Airport early on
Friday an attack that threatens to
dramatically ratchet up tensions in the
region now there are three different
responses that we've been seeing to come
into - so LeMay knees death response
number one is just bat bleep lunacy and
response number one is that we are sad
he's dead that the United States did
something wrong in killing Khomeini I
mean in killing Saleh mania rather
that's absolutely
insanity this is one of the worst people
on the planet the world is much better
off with him not breathing the same air
as the rest of us this is a person who
richly deserved to die he'd been an
American cross heads at crosshairs at
least a couple of times back in 2007 he
was in America's crosshairs he was also
in America's crosshairs back in I
believe 2014 or he was in Israeli
crosshairs back in 2014-2015 and the
Obama administration basically told the
Israelis not to kill him so he has been
under the gun several times he's not
been taken out obviously until yesterday
at that point he was taken out did he
deserve to die you bet your ass he
deserved to die just for the killing of
American soldiers he deserved to die for
the spread of Iran's terrorism around
the world so response number one which
you're seeing from people like Rose
McGowan the actress is just insanity the
idea that the United States did
something morally wrong in taking out
one of the leading terrorists on planet
Earth probably the leading terrorist on
planet Earth Rose McGowan who is a crazy
person tweeted out dear Iran the USA has
disrespected your country your flag your
people 52% of us humbly apologize we
want peace with your nation we are being
held hostage by a terrorist regime we do
not know how to escape please do not
kill us
hashtag Soleimani that that tweet
beggars description like there is no
there are no words for how evil and vile
and traitorous that tweet is I mean that
is just though it may be the worst tweet
ever written first of all the Iranian
people are not in line with Soleimani or
with the ayatollahs if they had their
way this regime would not be in power
second of all the idea that we are being
held in thrall to a terrorist regime and
you're apologizing for the death of Tara
I mean we don't have to take Rose
McGowan that seriously but there is that
sort of roiling undercurrent in the
comment area today that somehow Trump
did something wrong in killing Soleimani
so that's narrative number one narrative
number two is that this amounts to some
sort of assassination that it's an
assassination of a foreign official in
violation of American law that's a lie
okay this is not a violation of American
law there are only two laws that would
theoretically be implicated here one is
whether the United States with
authorized to take action whether
Congress had authorized that action well
under the authorization for use of
military force the United States has has
the President of the United States has
authority to act inside Iraq not only
that the Iraqi government has invited
the united states into iraq Soleimani
was not killed inside iran he was killed
in iraq he was a foreign terrorist in
Iraq and the United States had every
ability and from on a moral level every
moral obligation to kill assalam aunty
as far as the idea that this was some
sort of assassination violation of the
Reagan era executive order against
assassinations again this man was a
terrorist who's not just an Iranian
official he was a terrorist and he was
in a foreign countries that makes a
difference so this notion that this was
some sort of assassination is nonsense
and then there's the narrative that this
is an escalation in order for you
believe that this was a tremendous
escalation or that Trump is responsible
for the escalation you have to believe
that nothing has been happening over the
last couple of years which is just a lie
we've covered it on the show over and
over the Iranians have been attacking
shipping in the Straits of Hormuz
including internationally flag ships
over and over the Iranians have been
pursuing terrorism against American
interest and American allies and men
firing rockets on Americans in Iraq the
Iranians have been responsible for the
downing of an American drone and then
over the weekend
obviously they attacked an American
Embassy because that was done with solo
monies go ahead and that's what the
Defense Department suggested today the
Defense Department put out a statement
explaining exactly why they had just
done what they did the Pentagon said
quote at the direction of the president
US military has taken decisive defensive
action to protect US personnel abroad by
killing Qasem Soleimani
the head of the Iranian Revolutionary
Guard Corps hoods force a u.s.
designated foreign terrorist
organization general Soleimani was
actively developing plans to attack
American diplomats and servicemembers in
Iraq and throughout the region general
Soleimani and his Cootes force were
responsible for the deaths of hundreds
of American and coalition servicemembers
and the wounding of thousands more had
orchestrated attacks on coalition bases
in Iraq over the last several months
including the attack on December 27th
culminating in the death and wounding of
additional American and Iraqi personnel
general Soleimani also approved the
attacks on the US Embassy in Baghdad it
took place this week this strike was
aimed at deterring future Iranian attack
plans the United States will continue to
take all necessary action to protect our
people and our interests wherever they
are around the world and well this is a
ballsy move by Trump it's a ballsy move
by Trump the reason it's a ballsy move
by Trump is because it throws the
Iranian regime into chaos which means
that there will be short term lashing
out everybody knows it okay this is
going to happen the Iranian regime in
order
save face are obviously going to attempt
some sort of terror attack you know a
likelihood that will come against Saudi
targets you might see them try terror
attacks inside the United States you
might see them try terror attacks in
South America where they've tried terror
attacks before massive terror attacks
actually you might see them activate
Hezbollah in Lebanon to fire on Israel
things could get fairly hot fairly
quickly particularly for American allies
as far as the the wives of the sort of
projection of widespread attack on
Americans one thing is now clear that
the death of Soleimani shows that if
things get too hot Allah Khomeini will
not be connected with his head in very
short order yeah the fact is that what
Trump was doing yesterday was a
restorative American deterrents that had
been lost during the Obama
administration and yes in the early
years of the Trump administration the
fact is that the Obama administration
tried a strategy of outright bribery of
the world's worst terror regime they
lied to the American people in the
process the Iran nuclear deal was a
disaster for the United States it was a
disaster for the world it was an attempt
to pay off a terror regime a radical a
radical Islamic terror regime hell-bent
on regional domination and indeed on
world terrorism and the Obama
administration lied to you and they lied
to me and they lied to the American
people Ben Rhodes leading the way the
national security aid he was going out
there and lying and saying that there
was this tiny window in which the
moderates could take control varan if
only we paid them billions of dollars
hundreds of billions of dollars and
allowed hundreds of billions of dollars
to flow into the Iranian economy and
made them part of the family of nations
then all would be well that did not
happen the Iranians took that money they
immediately started developing the
ballistic missile program they
immediately started pushing terrorism
around the region John Kerry the
Secretary of State under Obama admitted
as much and the Trump administration
came in and they said okay we're not
going to sponsor this stuff we are not
going to allow dollars to flow into a
terror regime and Iran with its economy
sagging decided to lash out and
increasingly lash out now if you're on
the left you say well the lashing out is
Trump's fault okay that's that's like
suggesting that the lashing out by your
child when you punish them for hitting a
sibling and they're in their room
screaming you say the screaming is your
fault for punishing the kid well
actually the screaming is the kids fault
for hitting their sibling hey Iran
anytime it wants anytime Iran wants Iran
can
the family the nation's anytime Iran
wants it can be integrated into world
economy
anytime Iran wants Iran can be a
well-respected member of the world
community all they have to do is stop
being terrorist radical Islamist that's
it that's all they have to do but
they're not going to do that because
they're running a repressive oppressive
terror regime in Tehran and the fact
that the Trump administration
acknowledged that reality and the Obama
administration sought to back massage
the mullahs was the was the was the
initiating event that led to all of this
so Trump said he came off he said this
deal is no good he tore it up and then
the Iranians started lashing out and
then after lashing out and lashing out
lashing out four years after lashing for
literally years and the Trump
administration taking very light action
right they restored some of the
sanctions but after an American drone
was shot down there was talk that the
Jets were on their way the American
military was on its way to hit targets
in Iran and Trump called that off at the
last moment that after attacks on
shipping in the Straits of Hormuz the
United States is basically doing nothing
we saw repeated violations of
international law by the Iranians under
Obama they actually took a boat full of
Americans and held them at gunpoint
right after after and then they built a
statue of it in Tehran after all of that
this is the first sign that the United
States is going to restore its deterrent
capacity which is if you screw with us
you're going to die if you screw with us
the people at the top of your regime are
gonna be the ones who pay the price this
is a terror regime and your terror
leader just got killed
not just your terror leader your heir
apparent the head of your military
strategy the head of your terrorist
strategy that guy's dead
this was Trump's attempt to restore
deterrence now there are folks on the
left tour suggesting that deterrence
itself is a bad thing you can't deter
this regime you have to bribe them
that's called appeasement appeasement
typically has not worked all that well
you're gonna have to name the regime
that was appeased into relative safety
it has yet to happen in world history
that an evil regime acts evilly gets
paid for it and then acts less evilly
that is not something that happens in
the real world so you're seeing the
Democrats today saying well Trump just
ratcheted this thing up no Iran
ratcheted it up Trump responded to the
ratcheting by suggesting that if they
ratchet this thing too far some of them
are gonna die trying to re-establish
deterrence is necessary now that has to
be
one off that has to be consistent
strategy though there were those of us
were enraged that Barack Obama drew a
red line in Syria over a chemical
weapons use and then promptly proceeded
to blow right through the red line and
hand over power to the country to the
Russians which ended in disaster and
it's amusing today to watch all of the
Obama officials trotting out there
proclaiming their expertise after
completely wrecking the Middle East I
mean really making it much worse than it
was when Barack Obama entered office
when Barack Obama entered office the
Middle East was a much more stable place
than it is right now Barack Obama exited
Iran was a regional rising power many of
the American allies were in trouble hey
Donald Trump entered and he's attempted
to mitigate the effects of the horrible
Obama presidency and what we were
watching is the attempt to restore
deterrence in order for that to happen
the Trump administration has to do more
than one off that means that if Iran
strikes again then the United States is
going to have to take action against
Iran in different ways now none of this
has to lead to full-scale war everyone
keeps suggesting this is gonna lead to a
full-on all-out war between the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard and the US military
it is not the reason that it is not is
because the Ayatollah is no better than
anybody that if this thing goes to war
within three weeks they will all be dead
that doesn't mean that this would be an
easy war would not there would be
American losses no one wants a war no
one let me repeat no one wants a war
Trump II think Trump wants a war Trump
is by nature more of an isolationist he
doesn't want a war what he wants is
deterrence and he understands just like
Ronald Reagan understood that deterrence
can only be achieved with the credible
use of force and with the credible
threat of force when you are non
credible there is no deterrence and thus
the Iranians have no interest in pulling
back on their terrorist objectives
reestablishing deterrence is the goal
here we'll see how it worked out but I
don't think that it's gonna be a one-off
right I mean this is this is going to
result in the Iranians getting more
militants in the short term but the
United States and under President Trump
if they stay the course then this will
this will simmer down because there's
one thing the Iranians want even less
than the United States that is a full-on
war with the most powerful military
force in the history of planet Earth can
we get to more of this in just one
second we'll get to the Democratic
response which has been predictably
awful to all of that in just about
listen being nervous about what comes
next perfectly understandable suggesting
that this is quote unquote Trump's fault
and that will come
next is quote-unquote an Trump or that
the escalation is on Trump or that this
is the this is an assassination that
something morally wrong was done that's
just a bunch of horse crap it's not your
horse crap it would be the same if you
killed Osama bin Laden and people like
well you just escalated with al Qaeda I
don't know is that a good move or not
his home on e was one of the worst
people on the planet responsible again
for the deaths of hundreds if not
thousands of Americans responsible for a
vast amount of turmoil and death in the
Middle East in the short term when you
punish your kid your kid screams in
their room they make a lot of trouble
it's real bad but if you want to
reestablish deterrence you must must
establish a credible threat of force and
that's what Trump did yesterday we'll
get to more of this I'll give you more
details in just one second first
predicting the future is impossible as
you can see I mean it's a brand new year
and we're already talking about things
heating up in the Middle East this is
why you need to get life insurance rate
you just don't know what's coming what's
going to come down the pike this is
where policy genius can help policy
genius makes finding the right life
insurance a breeze in minutes you can
compare quotes from the top insurers and
find your best price you could save
1,500 bucks or more a year by using
policy genius to compare life insurance
policies once you apply the policy
genius team will handle all the
paperwork as well as the red tape and
policy genius doesn't just make life
insurance easy they can also help you
find the right home and auto insurance
or disability insurance so if your
science-fiction dreams for 2020 still
hadn't become science fact don't get
discouraged get life insurance it takes
just a few minutes to find your best
price and apply at policy genius calm
life is unpredictable so is death
unfortunately and this is why you need
life insurance also get all of your
other insurance taken care of while
you're over there are policy genius just
get this thing cleared off the decks for
the new year
policy genius we will always get the
future wrong so it's good to get life
insurance right and make sure that your
family is taken care of policy
genius.com go get it taken care of
competitive shopping makes your life
better and cheaper and faster and easier
policy genius.com go check them out
right now
all right so according to the Associated
Press the Defense Department's had
killed Soleimani because he was actively
developing plans to attack American
diplomats and servicemembers in Iraq and
throughout the region around supreme
leader Ayatollah Ali Khamenei
warned that a harsh retaliation is
waiting for the United States Iranian
state TV also carried a statement by how
many also calling Soleimani the
international face of resistance and he
declared three days of public mourning
for the generals death an advisory to
Iran's president Hassan rouhani warned
President
of retaliation from Tehran he said Trump
threw his gamble has dragged us into the
most dangerous situation in the region
is according to Hasan Minhaj shenna
whoever put his foot beyond the red line
should be ready to face its consequences
Iranian state television called Trump's
order to kill soleimani the biggest
miscalculation by the United States in
the years since World War two the people
of the region will no longer allow
Americans to stay well let's be real
about this the people of the region are
not fond of Iran the people of the
region do not like Iran Iran has turned
Lebanon which was once a blooming place
in the Middle East into an absolute
hellhole a hellhole a horror escape
they've helped her in Syria into a
horror escape they've turned a rock into
more of a horror escape here's video
from Iraq of people in the streets
cheering the death of Soleimani so let's
not pretend that this is just like the
Americans and and the Saudis and the
Israelis and the Jordanians who are
happy today the Iraqis are happy today -
this is people cheering in the streets
marching and cheering in the streets of
the news that Soleimani is dead you can
hear it I mean this is a good thing it's
a very good thing the airport strike
also killed Abu Motty alt Mohandas
deputy commander of iran backed militias
in Iraq known as the popular
mobilization forces that was the group
that was directly responsible for the
attacks on the US Embassy over the past
week five others were also killed
President Trump had only one quick
response that he sent out on Twitter
immediately following the attack and is
just a graphic of an American flag which
of course drove the left to distraction
for some odd reason why that is
controversial that it is a good thing
that the United States is responsible
for taking down the leading terrorists
on the planet I don't know why that
should be controversial that's it that
seems like a good thing to me the
Democrat responses to all of this are
just beyond loony they are they are
really really amazing Republicans
responded appropriately a bunch of
senators responded you saw for example
senator Ben Sasse respond and suggest
that this is a strong move by the by the
Trump administration said this is very
simple general Soleimani is dead because
he was an evil bastard who murdered
Americans the president made the brave
and right call and Americans should be
proud of our servicemembers who got the
job done by the way American military do
not F with the American military
tether on is on edge the moles have
already slaughtered at least a thousand
innocent irani
by the way media don't cover that they
never cover the protests that been
rolling across we're on free for now
about a year and before they lash out
further they should know that the US
military can bring any and all of these
IRGC butchers to their knees Ben Sasse
hitting the nail on the head right there
meanwhile the Democratic leaders are
responding in the worst possible way of
course Nancy Pelosi tweeted out American
leaders highest priorities to protect
American lives and interests but we
cannot put the lives of American
servicemembers diplomats and others
further at risk by engaging in
provocative and disproportionate actions
so it's disproportionate to kill the
leader of a terror group
disproportionate to kill terrorists just
so what what exactly is the proper
proportion he's responsible for the
deaths of hundreds of Americans and
terror attacks all over the globe and
conflict in Syria Lebanon Iraq and Yemen
as well as the Gaza Strip and this is
disproportionate in some way this is
this is who's planning further terror
attacks this is disproportionate the
Democratic responses I mean you think
that there are contrast between the
Democrats and the Republicans on foreign
policy when President Trump back
strongly the contrasts are absolutely
magnified I mean incredibly so ill had
Omar of course tweeted out the most
asinine response she's never met a
terror regime she's not willing to
defend she tweeted out what if Trump
wants a war knowing this leads to war
and needs the distraction yes I'm sure
this is a wag the dog scenario where
Trump is desperate for a war with Iran
because nothing spells re-election quite
like a war with a major regional power
no I mean as we know nothing spells
reelection quite like that
she says real question is will those
with congressional authority step in and
stop him I know I will stop him from
doing what exactly killing a terrorist
on Iraqi soil where the United States
has permission to be johann Omar again
this is the same lady who says we should
not have sanctions on Iran we shouldn't
have sanctions on Iran and Venezuela
according dillahunt Omar we should have
sanctions on Israel according to Ilhan
Omar so um I'm gonna go with no on her
hot takes on foreign policy meanwhile
you have members of the Obama
administration who are emerging to
defend their own crap foreign policy
which is what led to the rise of Iran
regionally in the first place
here is Obama's ambassador for the Iran
deal Wendy Sherman explaining that this
could have her if
consequences speaking of horrific
consequences how about you know like the
handing of 150 billion dollars in cash
pallets in cash on pallets to the
Iranian regime so they can explore
ballistic missile testing and spread
terror throughout the region was that a
one-off that may have had some bad
consequences here's Wendy Sherman being
a complete fool Qasem Soleimani had
deputies they know how to do what he did
even though he was this unbelievably
unique counter military strategist but
we are at a very very escalatory moment
here which can lead us into a wider war
I hope we do not go there I pray with
all of my heart that the Trump
administration has a plan and a strategy
but all I've seen to date in there
around policy is one-off actions and
this one-off action can have
unbelievably horrific consequences
really so that so like killing the
handing the Iranians billions of dollars
billions and opening their economy that
doesn't have any horrific actions except
for all of the horrific actions that
have happened for the past several years
killing the terror leader that's what's
going to have the horrific actions now
listen in the short term will the
Iranians respond yes they have to ray I
mean that they have to lash out because
they have to demonstrate that the regime
hasn't been crippled by solely money's
death and it is true that the United
States has have already said must have
contingency strategies here like what
happens if the Iranians to tackle US
base what happened the reason by the way
they're not going to attack an actual
hard American target is because at that
point things get real hot for the
Iranians and that regime is in serious
trouble right if they if they pursue a
9/11 style attack on US soil that's when
bleep gets real if they attack the US
base in in the Middle East the United
States will bring all of its power to
bear and mash whatever force is
attacking them wherever that attack is
occurring okay but but listening to
people like Ben Rhodes lecture us all on
American foreign policy is really
sickening I'll get some more of that in
just one second first let's talk about
your safety and security online the fact
is there are lots of people who are out
there looking for your data lots of
people trying to hack you lots of people
trying to grab all that data and use it
against you whether it is big tech that
is looking monitor you and use your data
and monetize your data or whether it's
just a hacker looking for your credit
card number I can say with full
confidence that it's
VPN is the VPN that I use and they are
the best VPN on the market expressive
VPN doesn't just log they don't log your
data lots of really cheap or free VPNs
will actually make money by selling your
data to add companies
well it's press VPN won't do any of that
they developed a technology called
trusted server that makes it impossible
for their servers to log any of your
info I like to do research on my
sponsors that's why I've been using
expressvpn at this point for literally
years and I feel much more protected
I've been I was hacked a couple of times
before that I've never been hacked while
using Express at VPN also Express VPN is
incredibly fast I've tried other VPNs in
the past and you download one of those
free VPNs and the big problem with
getting one of those VPNs is that really
slows down your computer not gonna
happen with expressvpn also Express VPN
is really easy to use you just fire up
the app that runs in the background of
your computer's not just me saying this
a huge number of tech websites have
already ranked via expressvpn the number
one VPN on planet Earth so protect
yourself with the VPN I use and trust
use my link expressvpn comm slash pen
today get an extra three months free on
a one-year package that's expressive VPN
calm slash pen that's expressive VPN
calm slash pendulum or expressive VPN
calm slash Ben so Ben Rhodes who's the
architect of the Iran nuclear deal and a
vast liar a huge liar to the American
people he tweeted out Congress has to
assert itself and determine exactly what
our Ron policy is did we mean to do this
so we have any plan for what comes next
what is the legal basis for all this
this is a guy who pursued an Iran policy
without congressional approval and then
did not submit it to Congress as a
treaty because he knew it would not get
through it's just it's amazing to watch
the Obama administration which botched
the Iran situation worse than any
administration since Jimmy Carter
running out there to proclaim that they
now have the knowledge and the expertise
to handle this thing got ben rhoades
tweeting does anyone think Donald Trump
is equipped to handle a complex enduring
international crisis that could play out
in many countries and demand expertise
rigorous process and judicious decision
making oh is that what that was when you
guys you know launched a war in Libya
without any sort of background and then
proceeded to let the entire place fall
into terrorists ruin and you allowed the
embassy in Benghazi to be overrun when
you allowed a bunch of American allied
regimes
to fall in the so-called Arab Spring
necessitating the rise of LCC in Egypt
in order to stop the Muslim Brotherhood
from taking over when the most populous
Muslim countries
planet Earth when you were like bribing
the Iranians was that what that was was
that the judicious decision-making that
we came to expect from people like Ben
Rhodes it's just it's just absurd I mean
it again listening to these folks is
just it's just ridiculous they have no
they have no credibility to speak on
these topics Joe Biden who's been wrong
on every single major foreign policy
decision of the last 40 years this is a
guy who militated against the bin Laden
kill hey I thought that was an easy call
going and killing bin Laden apparently
not Joe Biden Joe Biden put out a
statement he said President Trump just
tossed a stick of dynamite into a
tinderbox and he owes the American
people an explanation of the strategy
and plan to keep safe our troops an
embassy personnel are people in our
interest remember this got he Trump owes
an explanation on how to keep embassy
personnel safe you presided over
Benghazi from response to Baghdad was to
send in American troops preventing any
American death there and then to kill
their terror leader Biden said much
remains unknown but Iran will surely
respond we could be on the brink of a
major conflict across the Middle East
I hope the administration has thought
through the second and third-order
consequences of the path they have
chosen so it's all under it's all on
Trump but I fear this administration has
not demonstrated in any turn the
discipline or long-term vision necessary
and the stakes could not be higher again
as opposed to you bribing them it is
perfectly reasonable to be nervous about
what comes next it is perfectly
reasonable to ask what the Trump
administration's plans are but I'm not
gonna hear it from Joe Biden Joe Biden
has no credibility to speak on this
issue he presided over the worst Iran
policy since the initiation of the
Iranian Revolution in 1979 so no he does
not get - he does not get sound off on
this you know who else doesn't really
get sound off on this socialist Bernie
Sanders who's going around campaigning
with anti-semitic mouthpieces and who
spends his days kowtow to terror regimes
Bernie Sanders says Trump's dangerous
escalation it was Trump who escalated so
that that whole thing you know you seem
to remember it I know in your own mind
you seem to remember that part where
like them our embassy was on fire two
days ago that was all in your mind
you see Sanders tweeted up from
dangerous escalation
brings us closer to another disastrous
war in the Middle East that could cost
countless lives and trillions more
dollars you know how about the Americans
who are dead because of the Iranians
already said Trump promised
and endless wars but this action puts us
on the path to another one
you know it's an endless war trying to
bribe your way out of terror regimes
taking over the region I talked about
this yesterday with regard to Iran in
our response at the American Embassy I
talked about the fact that politically
speaking it is nearly always easier to
simply suggest that inaction is the best
pathway because there's no cost to
inaction in the near term it is only
when that manifests in terms of a vast
crisis that everybody goes oh we should
have done something about that it was
always easy for the Clinton
administration to pass up the hit on bin
Laden it was always easy for the Clinton
administration to cut the American
military and then taking on aggressive
posture in the Middle East and then 9/11
happens and everybody goes oh we should
have done something about that it's
always easy to slash America's military
to the bone as we did during the 1930s
and then Pearl Harbor happens I'm like
oh that was a bad idea huh in other
words aggressive action that is somewhat
preemptive in nature aggressive action
that establishes deterrence always bears
the immediate short-term risk of
retaliation but non action bears the
risk of a completely reshaped world map
that has vastly more consequences over
long-term than doing the things now that
prevent that stuff from happening later
it's very easy for Bernie Sanders to sit
there and decry war generally no one is
in favor of war no one wants war but the
Iranians are making more war more likely
because the stronger they get the more
aggressive they get that is the simple
fact this is the simple fact it wasn't
just Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden of
course it's a bunch of Democratic
Congress people speaking out in idiotic
fashion Tom Udall of Colorado he put out
a statement he said President Trump is
bringing our nation to the brink of an
illegal war with Iran with no
congressional approval it is not illegal
to kill a terror leader it is not
illegal if we go to full-scale war with
Iran yes that will meet congressional
approval and it should is Senator you
know passing our bipartisan amendment to
prevent unconstitutional war with Iran
is urgent Congress needs to step in
immediately to do what stop him from
killing terrorists
I don't remember Congress stepping in to
prevent a nuclear deal that basically
gave her on a clear pathway to a nuclear
weapon in ten years and then of course
you have Chris Murphy dholtze from
Connecticut whose Twitter account is
just a rapper
satori of stupidity he said the
justification for the assassination is
to deter future Iranian attacks okay
first of all it's not an assassination
an assassination implies that this
person is not a terrorist and was a
governmental official he was not he was
a terrorist this is one reason we don't
generally assassinate foreign political
officials is the belief that such action
will get more not less Americans killed
first of all it's fewer second of all
you you are terrible at does that should
be our real pressing and grave worry
tonight so in other words anytime you
kill a terrorist you have to worry then
it'll get more Americans killed I seem
to remember everybody celebrating bin
Laden dying soon remember that was that
again was that just my imagination
then you had Ed Markey of Massachusetts
senator from Massachusetts and he
tweeted out Trump's a parents
assassination of Soleimani is a massive
deliberate and dangerous escalation of
conflicts with with Iran again it's not
an escalation it is a recognition that
the conflict is already upon us they
tried to burn down the American Embassy
two days ago the president just put the
lives of every person in the region u.s.
servicemembers and civilians at
immediate risk the President did it's as
though the world started spinning
whenever Trump does something it's
incredible Trump is deranged these
people it's as though action in on
planet Earth only begins when Trump says
something about it
Trump is not God and everybody treating
him as though he is a unique figure in
history and that the world began
spinning every time he farts it's
ridiculous ed markey who's an idiot he
says we need de-escalation now oh you
mean paying them off Congress is the
only entity that can authorize military
force we cannot it must not get drawn
into war with Ron again trot you think
Trump wants war with Iran deterrence is
designed to avoid war it's why it's
called deterrence what do you think you
are deterring you're deterring Iran from
pursuing a more aggressive action across
the region if you believe that
deterrence doesn't exist if you believe
that deterrence is always a bad idea
then sure bribery seems like a great
strategy but guess what
bribing evil nations historically has
not worked out well it has not because
they just get more powerful and they get
more aggressive over time so yes by all
means we should worry about what comes
next yes by all means we should hope
that the Trump administration has a
strategy for dealing with the immediate
yes by all means we should harden our
our targets in the Middle East yes we
should be on high
alert yes we should be aware that the
Iranians are going to lash out and yes
we should have contingency plans
prepared for them lashing out we should
have a list of targets that we are going
to hit if they do XY and Z we have to
keep reinforcing to the Iranians that if
they continue to pursue this path there
will be consequences to that path that
is the only way to prevent war that's
the only way to prevent war if you want
a big bold war all you're gonna need is
for Iran to step across that border with
Saudi Arabia five years from now with
nuclear weapons and then things get real
hot you want to talk about World War 3
imagine that the Trump administration
left the Iranian at nuclear deal in
place had allowed billions upon billions
of dollars to flow into Iran the
ayatollahs to strengthen themselves
develop ballistic missiles create
nuclear weapons and then proceed to
launch actual overt wars with Saudi
Arabia Israel Jordan surrounding nations
imagine that because that's not far off
in the imagination but now they're armed
with nuclear weapons and there's nothing
you can do about it that was the Obama
administration's plan and they basically
admitted as much
so pretending that that we don't exist
in the course of a history as though
this is all tabula rasa brand-new it's
just it's historically ignorant and it
is cynical politicking beyond pretty
much all else all right we'll get to
more of this in just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you're
probably still receiving all those
Christmas and Hanukkah gifts people are
sending out a lot of packages the
beginning of the year you're getting all
of your tax documents ready like a lot
of stuff is happening and a lot of it's
coming through the mail when people
deliver your mail you want to know that
they are there and a lot of thieves will
if you ring your doorbell make sure that
you are not home and then rob your place
well this is one of the rate this is one
of the reasons why you should have ring
devices on your property to make sure
that your property is actually safe
rings mission is to make neighborhood
safer you might already know about their
smart video doorbells and cameras that
protect millions of people everywhere
ring helps you stay connected to your
home anywhere in the world so if there's
a package delivery or a surprise visitor
you will get an alert and be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone I've ring products all over my
house it makes me feel a lot safer
makes my - I feel a lot safer as well
listen swear I lived where my kids are
you get a lot of threats ring makes your
property safer as a subscriber you have
a special offer on the ring welcome kit
available right now and rings out
calm /ban the kit includes a ring of a
ring video doorbell and a chime Pro
which is just what you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home today go to ring comm slash Bend
that is ring.com slash men again
ring.com slash man go check them out
right now it will make your house safer
it'll make you feel safer and again you
can find out who's on your property any
time from anywhere
ringing comm / pendants ringing comm /
man okay before we go further here and
there is much more here first and it's a
glorious time of week we're at the end
of the first work week of the new year
and it is that time of week when I give
a shout out to a daily wire subscriber
today it is Falcon chance 91 on Twitter
who's already a clear front-runner for
2020 father of the year in this picture
his two adorable kids one infant and
toddler are snuggling in a chair making
dad proud the caption reads I know
liberals and leftists aren't the same
but I had to post it this picture of my
daughter wearing her I cry almost as
much as liberals onesie and her brother
holding our prized left his tears tumblr
Thank You Daily wire for providing such
great content hash tag left his tears
tumblr that is solid stuff it is our
pleasure to make this content we can
only do that because of subscribers like
you so thank you and thanks for the pic
you are definitely going to have your
hands full this year by the way 2020 you
know it's gonna be a crazy news filled
year I mean have you watched like the
first two days and we know that you need
to know everything that's going on the
best way to stay informed on all things
20/20 related is to become a daily Y
remember and get comprehensive news and
opinion from us on demand so we're
giving you 20% off all memberships until
January 6th yep that is 20% off all
memberships when you use promo code DW
2020 members get our articles add free
access to all of our live broadcasts and
show library the full three hours of the
ben shapiro show select bonus content
access to the mailbag and more plus our
new all-access tear he gets you into
live online Q&A discussions with me
Andrew Clavin Matt Walsh Michel moles
plus our sites writers and special
guests with all of the crazy complicated
election updates let us answer your
questions again that is promo code DW
2020 and get 20% off until Monday so do
it like right now join today stay
informed on all things 2020 related go
check it out right now
daily wire.com and use that code at DW
2020 for the subscription you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
so Mike Pompeo the Secretary of State
put out a statement he said I think the
Iranian leadership understands President
Trump will take action we made very
clear that these responses would be
swift and decisive we have now
demonstrated that I hope the Iranian
leadership will see that and see
American resolve and that their decision
will be to de-escalate and take actions
consistent with what normal Nations do
and the event they do not and they go in
the other direction I know the president
and the entire US government is prepared
to respond appropriately meanwhile the
presidents were on Hassan rouhani
promised early Friday to take revenge
for this heinous crime he also said that
Iran would raise the flag of Soleimani
in all likelihood what you're going to
see is a spate of attacks not as I say
directly on America but instead on
American allies in the region trying to
separate off those allies from the
United States with the help of the left
in the United States and isolationists
on the right so the idea would be to
attack Saudi targets and then dare
America to do something about it
suggesting that then it's America
escalating even more or attack Israel
and then if Israel responds then suggest
that it's that America was just doing
Israel's dirty business here by the way
that would be the worst mistake they can
make because right now let's say the day
decide to activate Hezbollah in Lebanon
and southern Lebanon against Israel
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu is
currently under indictment and is
sitting at the head of a government that
does not exist and he is currently
seeking immunity from indictment like
the worst thing they could do is try to
launch a war with Israel directly Iran
because if they do Israel is not going
to stand for it they are not going to
stand for it so I would i would guess
they're gonna taxi out a target's out
guess that they tried terror attacks in
different places around the world again
I doubt very much that they're going to
try something in the United States
directly would be a foolish move if they
are acting reasonably instead what they
would do is maybe make an attack in
Europe make attacks in South America
make attacks abroad elsewhere in the
region escalate things in Yemen that's
that's their likeliest path and by the
way as far as the details on on general
Qasem Soleimani the terror leader he was
apparently only identifiable by a large
ring that he wore on his finger because
he was so badly maimed in the strike
that there was not much left of him he
had arrived at the airport on a plane
from either Syria or Lebanon around
12:30 a.m. when he was met on the tarmac
by Abu Mahdi al Mohandas who's the
deputy commander of the pro Iran a
popular mobilization forces in Iraq that
was the specific umbrella terror group
that was responsible for the attacks on
the embassy on the Embassy's
Mohandas pulled up to the aircraft steps
in two cars before Soleimani and
Mohammad Rita Joffrey public relations
chief for the PMF climbed inside and
then were promptly driven away moments
later as the cars passed through a cargo
area headed for an access road leading
out of the airport that's according to
the Daily Mail the convoy was struck by
four missiles fired by an MQ for Reaper
drone both vehicles were instantly
reduced to smoldering wrecks killing
soleimani Mohandas jobbery and to others
who have yet to be identified and he was
only identified by this giant ring that
he was wearing the local militia
commander Abu munathara al husseiny told
Reuters Haj soleimani and Abu Maddy's
homo Hondas were riding in one vehicle
when it was struck by two successive
guided missiles launched from an
American helicopter while they were on
their way from the arrivals hall on the
road that leads out of Baghdad Airport
the second group was a bunch of
bodyguards who are also dead at this
point so that is the that is the current
situation and again we sort of a wait
what the response will be and the fact
is that that President Trump is now
tweeting again and so we are we are
getting his general take on the
situation he suggested this morning he
said the United States has paid off
billions of dollars a year for many
years that is on top of all else we have
done for them the people of Iraq don't
want to be dominated and controlled by
around but ultimately that is their
choice over the last 15 years Iran has
gained more and more control of Iraq the
people of Iraq are not happy with that
it will never end well he said general
Qasem Soleimani was killed or bet has
has killed or badly wounded thousands of
Americans over an extended period of
time and was plotting to kill many more
but got caught he was directly and
indirectly responsible for the death of
millions of people including a recent
large number of protesters killed in
Iran itself while Iran will never be
able to properly admit it soleimani was
both hated and feared within the country
there not nearly as sadden as the
leaders will let the outside world
believe he should have been taken out
many years ago and then he also tweeted
Iran never won a war but never lost a
negotiation in other words come to the
table now or we can continue killing all
of your friends so that by the way if
you've ever speak to members of the
American military today many of whom
have buddies who are killed by soli
Monte's forces in Iraq overwhelmingly
the feeling is one of joy that Soleimani
is dead this does not mean that all
questions are answered right all
questions are not answered obviously we
don't know what's going
happen from here and everybody is sort
of bracing for what the Iranian response
will be but there is no question that a
very good thing happened with Soleimani
being dead and the fact is that
deterrence must be restored if America
is not seen as a power capable of
deterring its enemies and it has no
power at all the Trump derangement
syndrome by the way is unbelievably
strong out there right now
max boot who was once a somewhat
respected foreign policy thinker
max boot goes on CNN and he suggests
that the Iran crisis is created by Trump
this is the same max boot who wrote a
piece in July of 2015
called the dawn of Iranian empire
talking about the evils of the Iran
nuclear deal and why it was a mistake to
try and bribe them and now here he is on
CNN just a few years later declaring
that the best solution would be -
presumably to bribe the Iranians or - or
to never retaliate against their
increasing and escalating aggression
this is a crisis that President Trump
has really created between the u.s. and
Iran because all of the u.s. and Iran
have a long history of animosity dating
back to 1979 relations that actually
quieted down quite a bit since President
Obama concluded the Iranian nuclear deal
in 2015 and last year even though the
Iranians were complying with the Iranian
nuclear deal President Trump decided to
blow up the deal and then he imposed
unilateral economic sanctions on Iran
this year which have been a lot more
effective than a lot of people including
me expected the way the Iranians view
that is the u.s. is waging economic
warfare on them and they need to strike
back so there is max boot completely
flipping his own position on the Iran
nuclear deal basically because Donald
Trump happens to be President again if
Barack Obama had done this exact same
thing and it's amazing to watch these
people Barack Obama droned American
citizens overseas who are terrorists and
people on his side of the aisle were
like no problem everything's great
Donald Trump orders the death of an
Iranian terrorist in a foreign country
and it was an assassination illegalities
absolute sheer nonsense now again
consistent foreign policy must be had
going forward we must see a consistent
foreign policy going forward deterrence
only works if you continue to deter if
you if you warn people if you keep
crying wolf about what exactly you're
gonna do when somebody harms you then
eventually people are gonna stop taking
me seriously
but with all of that said selling
money's death makes the world a better
place now we just see what happens next
it mean
Wow the 2020 Democratic race is heating
up and the Democrats are racing to say
the next stupid thing Joe Biden came out
yesterday and suggested that he wants a
national bag ban and these are sort of
serious times here is Joe Biden
suggesting that it's time to ban plastic
bags in Kenya we are trying to clean
their environment not plastic bags you
go with your own the market well I agree
with you 100% we should not be allowing
plastic and what we should do is phasing
it out and if you noticed but we're
running a problem right now the problem
is we were president says there is no
problem deeply important issues being
taken on by the Biden campaign like
plastic bags by the way if you want to
understand why the left why the
Europeans are constantly attempting to
pretend that george w bush was the
aggressor in the Middle East or Israel
is the aggressor in the Middle East or
Saudi Arabia or Jordan depending on the
situation Egypt these are all the
aggressors in the Middle East the bottom
line is that anybody who is perceived as
either American European or an American
or European ally in the Middle East is
perceived as the bad actor and the
reason is because the West is constantly
seen as the source of all malignity
malignity and an evil in the world Joe
Biden is the least like this in the
Democratic Party and even he does some
of this yesterday there was a big
controversy because Biden said something
that was taken out of context there was
a clip but Biden appearing to suggest
that America was built on European
culture and this was apparently
extremely controversial and people were
going crazy over it except that's not
what he was saying what he was saying
was actually extraordinarily stupid and
horrible what he was saying is that
European culture is uniquely anti-woman
here is Joe Biden explaining the
if you're going to Penn or Harvard or
Yale or with brown or whatever and you
have to publish how many times so
someone's been abused like well I send
my kid there
I'm serious think of the fight back but
we finally got a lot of pass through
when the Secretary of Education was a
great guy that I worked with and others
under tight line then it came along came
Betsy DeVos
I'm serious it ended it ended it folks
this is about changing the culture our
culture our culture it's not important
from some African nation or some Asian
nation
it's our English jurisprudential culture
our European culture which says it's all
right here the same blame America first
blame Europe first mentality that leads
to the bizarre notion that violence
against women is unique Western
invention which by the way look at the
world likes to globe there are lots of
countries on that globe if you're a
woman where would you prefer to be born
on that globe the answer European
countries countries with European
influence America Australia Canada
Western countries in other words okay
you would not prefer to be born in
sub-saharan Africa in most parts of Asia
you would not prefer to be born in the
Middle East and there are lots of places
on planet earth you would not prefer to
be born if you were a woman and want to
be treated with respect
but according to Joe Biden America's
culture of violence against women is
purely European in origin and then he
cites bad history to push all of this
it's that mentality that the soft
bigotry of low expectations when it
comes to other countries that leads to
the idea that when America retaliates
against terrorists that is America's
fault for escalating again it is very
easy for Iran to make all of this go
away just stop acting like terrorists
pieces of crap that's it
okay that's all you have to do all the
Iranian government has to do to be
welcomed in is to stop this this has
been true for ever there was no point at
which this was not true and yet they are
not and yet it is people in the West
suggesting that it is Trump's fault or
it was Bush's fault apparently the only
possible solution to the intransigence
of evil countries and evil aggressors is
to bribe them because in the end we are
the true evil aren't we in the end it's
America it's Europe those are those are
the places that are that are the cause
of all evil in the world that sort of
self-loathing leads to some pretty awful
consequences and again when it comes to
Iran things are gonna get hot before
they get cold but if you want things to
cool down if you would like a cold war
with Iran rather than a hot war with
Iran you're gonna need to stop arming
the enemy and then suggest
that the regional aggression has no
consequences whatsoever while handing
them pallets of cash visit the this
whole blowback for Trump for doing what
is obviously a moral and right thing
without seeing what comes next I think
waiting to see what comes next is is
pretty astonishing okay time for some
things I like and then we'll do some
things that I hate so things that I like
over the break I had the opportunity to
watch some of the movies that have
finally come out streaming and finally
they brought up Joker now I had to watch
Joker screaming as opposed to in the
theaters specifically because I couldn't
take my wife to see this movie there are
certain movies that I just like Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood also couldn't
take my wife to see that one Joker
couldn't take my wife to see it I was
very eager to see it I have some
critiques have some thoughts here's a
little bit of preview and then I will
explain what's good about the movie and
what's not so great about the movie
[Music]
so awful isn't it
my whole life
if I even really existed
I do
starting to notice
okay so the whole movie is based around
Joaquin Phoenix's performance which is
indeed a terrific performance what works
about the film is his personal descent
into evil right that all works and
there's a great team with Robert De Niro
near the end of the film in which he
talks about his feeling of dispossession
of being mocked yeah all of that stuff
works what doesn't work about the film
for me is if you imagine that he's the
counterpart to Batman right so if you
imagine that he is supposed to be so
clever that he's supposed to be such a
villain that Batman can never quite get
his arms around him then it doesn't work
at all because basically he is not a
brilliant person he is not a genius he
doesn't do anything in premeditated
fashion he doesn't have any plan he
doesn't have any forethought and so the
notion that Batman would have a tough
time catching this guy is bizarre like
he gets caught three times basically and
put in jail and then released and that
of course is part of the Batman comics
because he's released on mental health
recognizance effectively but the idea
that he is sort of the notorious
counterpart to Batman that part like if
you imagine the Joker movie in the
Batman universe it doesn't work on its
own it works perfectly fine as the
descent of one person living in bad
social circumstances into evil and the
self justification that comes from it
that that'll work and of course Joaquin
Phoenix is probably the best living
American actor on the stage he really is
first-rate okay time for a quick thing
that I hate so the New York Times is now
making a big deal out of this this
homecoming video from the University of
Wisconsin the the video is is utterly
non-controversial here's a little bit of
the video and then I'll explain what's
controversial about this because there
really is nothing controversial about
this where we can all harmonize as one
to show some people singing home is
Wisconsin cheese curds
it's welcoming everyone into our home
shows people walking for the campus home
some night some of these young women
going swimming it's where we can let
some young women dancing in all this
[Music]
okay so what was so controversial about
this homecoming video which is just like
that of a cute nice video and it was the
homecoming committee that made the video
too many white people really this is
this is the critique the New York Times
had a big piece about how in a
homecoming video meant to unite campus
almost everyone was white if you watch
that video in your first reaction is
where are all the black people I would
suggest that you are a little bit too
focused on race in the world this was
not meant to be a white pride video
there is literally nothing about this
video that screams white pride the fact
that there aren't as many black faces in
it as you would presumably like does
that like are you imputing racism to the
campus are you imputing racism to the
students who made it like where exactly
is the critique it's it's an absurd
absurd thing but this merited this huge
long New York Times article the video
was just two minutes long
a sunny montage of life at the
University of Wisconsin's flagship
campus in Madison here were hundreds of
young men and women cheering at a
football game dancing in unison riding
bicycles in a sleek line throwing the W
for the camera singing acapella leaping
into a lake home is where we grow
together a voiceover said days before
homecoming week the student homecoming
committee tasked with producing the
video posted it online the outrage was
almost instantaneous virtually every
student in the video was white well
maybe that's because the vast majority
of students at University of
wisconsin-madison or white there are
30,000 undergrads at UW Madison fewer
than a thousand of them are black so
maybe the statistical pool from which
you are drawing is overwhelmingly white
and so the video is overwhelmingly white
does that mean that this is like people
well we can't cast this black person in
the homecoming video none of that
happened none of that happened but
according to students of color the
homecoming video was a glimpse of what
they experienced every day as they walk
through campus the video prompted a
burst of student activism and attempt by
university officials to educate ou about
diversity and a reckoning over who feels
at home at the University of Wisconsin
it's so tiresome the faux outrage is so
tiresome oh my god there weren't enough
black people in this homecoming video
how terrible
well I guess this means that we are five
seconds away from the reinstitution of
segregation you know who else I didn't
see a lot of Orthodox Jews in that video
and see how to keep poet in that video
clearly it's an answer somatic campus
what are we even talking about the
answers we're talking about nothing
people are looking for a reason to be
outraged and we live in a stupid place
right now a very stupid time in a very
stupid place alrighty we'll be back here
a little bit later today with two
additional hours of content all the new
developments plus if you don't want that
we'll be back here next week now is the
time to subscribe by the way because
Monday our special subscription offer
ends our 20% to offer so use DW 2020
when you go to daily wire comm and pick
up a subscription go do that right now
otherwise have yourself a wonderful
weekend I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Rebecca Dodd poets directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producers Mathis Glover and Robert
Stirling technical producer Austin
Stephens associate producer Colton Haas
assistant director Pablo why douse key
edited by Adam Sai events audio is mixed
by Mike Romina hair and makeup is by
Jeff while alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the Matt Walsh oh we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
[Music]